Have you ever heard of dragonflies that snipe
their prey with bolts of energy?
Or octopuses that serve as guard dogs?
Or Necromancer Bees that live in reanimated
carcass-hives?
These images aren’t pulled from some bizarre
medieval manuscript.
Nor are they long-lost Renaissance paintings.
These are from the Codex Inversus — a modern
worldbuilding project from the imagination
of the brilliant artist and writer Luca Vanzella.
Brought to life through collages of classical
art, the world of Codex Inversus is full of
flora and fauna that have evolved to use magical
energy, visitors from parallel dimensions,
and fractures in space and time.
At a glance, the surreal, scrambled visuals
are difficult to make sense of.
Yet like a medieval bestiary, the project
does follow a unique system of internal logic.
So, for this entry into the archive, I’ll
investigate the creatures, people, and locations
of this scrambled world — and reveal the
hidden order to the chaos of Codex Inversus…
The land of Codex Inversus exists in the wake
of a cosmic upheaval known as the Collapse
— where all extradimensional realms crashed
into the material world, releasing vast magical
energies that altered reality.
Understanding the realm as it exists today
is no easy task, for the world is full of
strange oddities.
Yet we must start somewhere.
In the center of the northernmost continent
lies the Valley of Delights, a relatively
safe and idyllic region where magic practitioners
create surreal sights.
But it’s not just people casting the magic.
In Codex Inversus, even small creatures — like
the bizarre Transmuter Snail — have evolved
to use simple spells.
In their neutral form, a Transmuting Snail
is indistinguishable from an ordinary snail.
Yet if, say, a plant is out of reach, a Transmuter
Snail will move their eye stalks in specific
patterns to rapidly change their body, gaining
frog-like legs for jumping.
If trying to cross a puddle, a Transmuter
Snail might adopt a ‘swimming form,’ gaining
a tail similar to a tadpole’s.
And when trying to carry an object, these
snails might even gain a long prehensile appendage
— equivalent to an octopus tentacle...
The first human spellcasters, called the Evokers,
learned how to wield magic by studying animals
like the Transmuter Snail.
These early wizards found that existence can
be shifted with the right pattern… and that
pulling on the threads of reality can be dangerous.
For spells in Codex Inversus are strange and
unpredictable, often altering the user’s
physical body beyond recognition.
And in the Valley of Delight, some spellcasters
have also begun altering the biology of animals.
The Chimericat is the result of artificial
speciation through transmutation magic.
With a spring-like body and piercing tail,
Chimericats are designed to be the ultimate
form of pest control.
For while the valley is an idyllic locale,
it has a bit of a rat problem.
Manticorats are winged rodents that never
evolved to cast spells themselves, but are
quite adept at sniffing out magical ingredients
on which to feed.
And while the Chimericats proved effective
at catching the Manticorats, now the valley
is overrun with Chimericats instead…
In Codex Inversus, human attempts to rewrite
existence often end with disaster.
Yet following the collapse of other realms
into the material world, humans now share
territory with wiser, formerly mythic beings.
North of the Valley of Delights, the long-lived
Elves build their eternal kingdoms.
Elves possess a greater understanding of how
to safely cast spells than humans, and specialize
in controlling the elements.
In the mountains of the south, subterranean
Dwarves are more practical in their reality
manipulation, creating artificial beings to
aid in their mining.
And there’s another tunneling lifeform native
to the southern continent.
Abjuring Termites are capable of incredible
feats of engineering.
They have evolved to cast spells — not with
their bodies, but with the shape of their
tunnels.
Through the digging of complex patterns, Abjuring
Termite nests are protected by a low-level
spell, and are virtually indestructible.
Termite farms have become novelty items, with
some individuals putting them on display and
asking guests to try and smash them.
Which is physically impossible.
Yet the termites still have predators.
The Mudpecker is a bird that uses stealth
to catch termites: inserting their thin beaks
in the nest's pores without causing immediate
alarm and slurping clean one or two tunnels
before the defenses are alerted.
It’s a strategy similar to ordinary woodpeckers,
and suggests that sometimes the best path
is the one of least resistance…
In the southernmost region of the world, perhaps
the strangest lifeforms of all are the Matras.
Sentient constructs of unknown origin, these
clockwork beings strive to replace chaotic
biological life with precise and reliable
artificial creatures.
Most notably, the Matras oversee the Enigma
Library, a collection of texts no one is able
to translate.
The artificial, cube-headed Curators of this
library search for a ‘Grand Diagram’ — a
complete and comprehensive explanation of
how the Collapse warped creation.
So far, they have found nothing...
The primordial chaos of the Collapse has changed
some populations in incredible ways.
The seafaring Halflings possess bodies that
defy perspective.
Like living optical illusions, they seem to
have pieces missing from certain angles.
These unsettling gaps, which are common on
hands and arms, cause no pain, and are the
result of parts of their bodies phasing through
dimensional reality.
And as is often the case in Codex Inversus,
certain animals have evolved to take advantage
of similar magical phenomena.
Conjuring ants are tiny insects with an impressive
secret.
Like ordinary ants, Conjuring Ant society
is mainly preoccupied with transporting food
back to the nest for later consumption.
But Conjuring Ants have found a faster method
than carrying food themselves.
By moving in a specific pattern around a piece
of vegetation, Conjuring Ants can fold spacetime
and teleport food directly back to the nest…
To the north, reality becomes even further
warped.
Here, a marine paradise coexists with a prairie.
Known as the Ethereal Ocean, this environment
is possible due to out-of-phase water in the
sky that various fish swim through.
All animals here can interact with each other
even if they respond to different environmental
conditions.
Small fishes graze the fur of horses, sharks
hunt flocks of birds, and spiders weave webs
to catch flying shrimp.
In this vast region where the sky behaves
like the sea, certain groups of wizards have
domesticated octopuses — which fill a role
similar to dogs or cats.
Some breeds of octopuses are able to hunt
for vermin and scare off intruders, while
others are clever enough to fetch tools and
alchemical ingredients.
Some Magi Octopuses can even cast small spells
— although they are too shy to do so in
public…
The Ethereal Ocean is part of a kingdom called
the Angelic Unison.
Ruled by the ethereal descendants of celestial
beings, the land is a place where anything
can happen.
A realm of infinite wonders, at the heart
of the Angelic Unison are grassy plains populated
by cosmic animals.
Stargazing Cows are inherently magical creatures
that produce milk with calming and relaxing
properties.
The restless Insomniac Sheep are the cows’
opposite, with their milk acting as a natural
stimulant — making sheep’s butter a popular
breakfast food across the kingdom.
Yet the most important animals in the Angelic
Unison are the Holy Cows.
Descendants of extradimensional animals from
before the Collapse that interbred with their
earthly counterparts, Holy Cows possess the
ability to quell aggression just by looking
at someone.
Their halo-horn signifies their importance,
and their milk always tastes sweet, even when
spoiled — which can actually be problematic,
and can cause sickness if one isn’t careful.
The Angelic Unison is a kingdom where almost
all things possess some level of extradimensional
distortion.
Even stones take on fantastical properties
in the Floating Plains —a region famed for
its slabs of levitating rock.
While an interesting novelty, these boulders
can also be something of a nuisance — disrupting
herds and keeping rain from watering crops.
On the western edge of the continent, the
independent Nation of Beasts has formed.
Here, many groups of humanoids with animal
features gather together under one banner,
and cast unique spells.
In crowded cities, the Cat-Folk are a common
sight, filling the nights with the sounds
of their serenades.
Unfortunately for the general populace, to
be a good singer, or just in tune, is not
a prerequisite.
Cat-Folk are also excellent weavers and spellcasters.
Animal-folk in general have a unique attitude
towards magic, seeing the energies of the
dimensional field as conscious, and spells
a way of "asking" the field for assistance,
rather than controlling it.
Snake-Folk are another common resident in
cities, preferring to stay indoors due to
their cold-blooded physiology.
Their ancestral fangs make chewing difficult,
and so they have a unique culinary tradition
based around soft foods.
Snake-Folk cuisine has become famous across
the continent, and many serpents now run popular
taverns.
Shambling in the back alleys of the beasts’
cities are unnerving pests.
The bodies of deceased animals have been spotted
moving seemingly of their own accord, surrounded
by buzzing insects.
These corpses are, in fact, the mobile hives
of Necromancer Bees.
These bizarre insects have come up with an
ingenious way of scaring off predators — by
hijacking the expired bodies of animals larger
than they are.
Necromancer Bees reanimate animals using rather
complicated spells for such tiny insects — moving
in different formations called ‘dances’
to get the muscles of their hives working
once more.
Strange as this might sound, ordinary bees
can actually perform complicated dances to
communicate the direction and distance of
flowers to their fellow hive members…
Deeper within the Nation of Beasts is a bleak
landscape dominated by cubes of rock that
look like they fell from the skies.
Known as the Hades Badlands, the region is
a land of oblivion, where reality unravels
due to the cubes’ strange properties.
Those who pass through may lose their memory,
their minds, or their physical form.
Even deeper within the Beast Nation, the secretive
Raven-Folk keep watch over the Ghost Forest.
While they interact and trade with the other
nations, they do not permit anyone to enter
their mysterious domain.
For while the Ghost Forest might appear like
an ordinary grove, the fog works as a pocket
dimension, which some plants and animals have
evolved to ‘phase’ in and out of.
One such plant is the Starberry, which produces
an enticing fruit.
It wants to be eaten, but not by ‘ghost
animals,’ since they can ‘phase out’
the seeds during digestion.
To prevent this, the fruit possesses a cage
of thorns that stings only ‘ghosts’ — with
mortals able to pass through it unharmed.
Eating a Starberry means putting the bramble
into your mouth, which can be unsettling even
if you know it won't sting.
The haunting Ghost Lilies are perhaps the
most important plants of the Ghost Forest.
These mind-altering flowers evokes memories
and a sense of nostalgia when smelled or ingested.
This property has made the lilies a luxury
good, and a common export to more distant
parts of the realm…
In the margins of the Codex Inversus world,
one of the rarer and more destructive creatures
are the Evoker Dragonflies.
These insects are carnivorous, and they hunt
like sharpshooters: waiting for their prey
and then striking from afar with impressive
spells summoned from their tails.
To resist the recoil of the bolt, evoker Dragonflies
must use their claws to grab whatever they
are standing on.
The kickback of their dart is also used proactively
as propulsion by the dragonflies, with the
insect shooting a bolt in the opposite direction
they are headed — propelling them at high
speeds towards their destination.
And destructive magic isn’t limited to insects.
Ancient scriptures say that beings known as
the Fairies once wandered the world, spreading
ruin for no reason other than their own amusement.
The even grimmer counterparts of the Fairies
— the Nightmares — also tormented the
land, and drew the ire of the Angelic Unison.
The angelic beings used the last spark of
their divinity to banish them to the two moons
that orbit the planet, since other dimensions
no longer existed after the collapse.
The Nightmares were sent to the Onyx moon,
where scripture says they remain to this day
— ravenous and waiting for a chance to take
their revenge.
The fairies were banished to the Jade moon,
and faded into myth over the passing centuries.
Yet recently, sightings of eerie creatures
wearing domes of jade on their heads have
begun, and strange lights appear in the sky
when the moons are full…
Across the world of Codex Inversus, perhaps
no location is as fabled or as feared as the
Elsewhere Woods.
A piece of crumbled space where reality folds
like paper, the Elsewhere Woods are a place
where lost things go.
Some say towers of slithering flesh with geometric
summits rise among the trees, their origin
and function unknown.
Others claim the woods are made of many different
trees from all over the world — with patches
of pine forest and stripes of tropical jungles,
brambles from arid lands fading into wet fields
of reeds.
Floating among these branches are white Cloud-Possums
— inquisitive marsupials that hover as if
they weigh nothing at all.
Some reports claim fearsome Owl-Griffins prowl
the Elsewhere Woods, defending their territory
with fierce attentiveness.
What truth there is in such fables is difficult
to say, for few return from the Elsewhere
Woods with their lives.
One of the few well-documented beings of the
Elsewhere Woods is the Illusionist Butterfly.
Also spotted in other parts of the world,
these insects have an impressive form of camouflage.
From their caterpillar stage, Illusionist
Butterflies are able to change color to match
their surrounding environment with uncanny
precision.
Following metamorphosis, however, they hide
in a different way.
The venations of their wings form a pattern
capable of casting an illusion spell.
Many real butterflies have spots on their
wings that essentially serve the same purpose
— mimicking the eyes of predators to scare
off would-be attackers.
Yet the Illusionist Butterfly takes this a
step further, with their patterns capable
of creating an illusory owl that moves and
flies next to its creator.
These owl projections are rarely complete,
with their bodies appearing and disappearing
in a waving shape.
Still, it’s an incredible form of camouflage
— that shows when in the Elsewhere Woods,
things are seldom what they appear.
Entering the Elsewhere Woods is no easy task,
for the region cannot be accessed through
mortal means.
There are rumors that the skulls of cyclops
— giant beings who went extinct long ago
— act as natural portals into the Elsewhere
Woods.
Monsters of unknown origin stalk the caverns
where these skulls can be found — chimeras
made from many different beings.
Reports describe creatures with tentacles
arms, necks which split into fanged mouths,
and disturbing heads shaped like crying children.
Yet where could such nightmares have come
from?
Some have theorized that the cyclops skulls
connect to other places with spatial anomalies.
There are rumors of a land beyond the ocean,
far from any known landmass, lit by a fracture
in space known as The Second Horizon.
No one from the known world has reached the
shores of this land, although many have tried.
According to legend, the land is populated
with three-eyed people — a lineage different
from any other.
Their land is also populated with Hammergulls
— seagulls with the heads of hammerhead
sharks.
What truth is there to such strange tales?
No one can say for certain.
For in the margins of Codex Inversus, there
will always be things which evade all understanding...
Observing the world of Codex Inversus is like
looking through a fractured window, with the
images shifting and merging before your eyes.
Yet this scrambled world of fables and myth
follows its own kind of rules if one looks
closely enough.
There are countless other strange and wondrous
aspects of Codex Inversus I wasn’t able
to cover here, and you can see more of the
art and read more of the narrative using the
links in the description.
And if you find this world as interesting
as I do, I encourage you to follow and support
Luca Vanzella, who is continuing to flesh
out this dreamlike realm.
Once again, links are down below.
And as always, thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this entry, please lend your
support by liking, subscribing, and hitting
the notification icon to stay up to date on
all things Curious.
See you in the next video.